let's talk about remote work
welcome back to another episode of
Udacity career tips my name is Martin
McGovern and today we have a question
from you the audience
today's question comes from LinkedIn and
asks can you make a video on how to
search for a remote job what are the
efforts one has to put in to achieve a
remote job and if possible and the pros
and cons of remote job this can help a
lot of people like me I'll be waiting on
the video thank you so much for your
question
this is definitely something that's on a
lot of people's minds so we're gonna get
into it today now your question is in
three parts so I'm going to break it up
over three different videos in order to
address each piece fully the first piece
how do you get a remote job it's a big
question and there's a lot of different
answers but if you go to Udacity z--
career resources you'll find that we
have a page dedicated to this in the
career resources there's a page about
employment types and it breaks down the
difference between a contract a
freelance and a full-time role if you
scroll down lower in the page you'll see
that there are three different remote
work job boards that have been listed
here the first one is remote okay and
they help you find opportunities based
off of your programming language so if
you know what language you're interested
in pursuing this is a great place to
start to find some remote work the next
one on the list is we work remotely
they specialize in helping people find
roles that are location agnostic and
commute free so if you're just looking
for general advice on remote work
definitely start there and the final
resource we have on this page is
producthunt this is a fantastic page to
go to because it lists every other
possible site that lists remote work so
that you can find the opportunity that
is best for you so check out the link
below and see if there's any
opportunities that fit your skill set if
you're someone who has a remote role and
you have some other resources please
share them in the comments and help the
rest of the community so we can all
build careers that we love I appreciate
the question we'll be bringing you part
two and part three in the coming weeks
so keep an eye out and if you have any
questions of your own please put them in
the comments and we'll be making more
videos in the months to come
thank you again for watching if you know
anyone who's searching for a job right
now tag them and let them know you're
thinking about them and we look forward
to seeing you again next week
you